hello there today we're looking at
self-supervised
learning the dark matter of intelligence
this was written by yan lakan and ishan
misra
of facebook ai research and it is not a
paper it is more a blog post
shared on the facebook ai blog and it
outlines the current state of
self-supervised
learning what it is and what it can do
why the authors
think it is important it goes over
things like birth
goes over things like contrastive
learning energy based models
gans and so on and at the end it gives a
bunch of
recommendations for the way to go
forward on a high level
the main recommendation is that we
should build
latent variable prediction models
that are not trained contrastively and
we'll go through all of what this means
in this article so
we'll go through the article i'll switch
over to here where it's a bit of a
more legible format and as always
if you like content like this if you
enjoy it
share it out don't hesitate to tell a
friend about it
alright let's do it they say in recent
years the ai field has made tremendous
progress in developing ai systems
that can learn from massive amounts of
carefully labeled
data so the keywords here are
massive amounts yes we got that but
carefully labeled data of course we all
know that supervised
learning has worked very well
if you have enough labeled data and
that's exactly
the problem in order to push machine
learning
to more to higher abilities
it seems like what we need is first of
all bigger architectures which we can do
by just building bigger computers
but we also need more data the problem
here is that
we need orders of magnitude more data
and labeling that data
is going to be very very expensive
and therefore we're looking for methods
that can do
without labeled data that can learn most
of what they learn
from non-labeled data and then
apply that to a little bit of label data
in order to learn a task
but this is not the only thing so the
need the expensiveness of labeling is
not the only thing
that they criticize here they say this
paradigm of supervised learning
has a proven track record for training
specialist models that perform extremely
well
on the tasks they were trained to do
so this is another criticism right here
namely that if we train
something in a supervised fashion with
labels it will become or it might become
very good but it will be very good at
that particular task
and it won't be super good at other
tasks
such as you know tasks that are
relatively
neighboring to the field that we're
concerned about
they go on they say that supervised
learning is a
bottleneck for building more intelligent
generalist models that can do multiple
tasks and acquire new skills
without massive amounts of labeled data
this is into the direction of
francois chole who defines intelligence
as the efficiency with which you
transform
new data into new skills and this
is reflected here in this article by jan
lakka and
and i'm sorry ishan but uh young lucan
just has the big name
and uh unfortunately you're a bit in his
shadow here
but i'm fairly confident these that
yanuka is not just on this for the name
because
the arguments in this article he has
raised in
many uh talks that i've seen of him in
the past few
years so it is it is really kind of a
condensing of
all of these talks in this here but
back to the paper this acquiring new
skills without massive amounts of
labeled data
they say that has to be our goal because
it is impossible to label everything in
the world
and there are also some tasks where
there is not enough labeled data
like translation systems for low
resource
languages so they make two
observations right here first of all
they say
look um
here for example if we show just a few
drawings of cows
to small children they'll eventually be
able to recognize any cow they see
by contrast ai systems trained with
supervised learning require
many examples of car images and might
still fail to classify cows in unusual
situations
such as lying on a beach what are you
doing
silly cow don't lie on a beach um
so this is another point right these
these ai systems
they take so much more data than humans
uh to learn new skills and
they ask why the short answer is that
humans rely on their previously
acquired knowledge of how the world
works
so they make this they make this
argument here that there is a thing
like common knowledge about the world or
common sense
it forms the bulk of biological
intelligence in both humans and animals
humans are animals like okay
this common sensibility is taken for
granted
but has remained an open challenge in ai
research common sense they say
is the dark matter of artificial
intelligence
so they point out that you have this
common sense
that you learn simply by interacting
with the world
they say as babies we learn how the
world works largely by observations
you form predictive models about the
world
you learn concepts such as object
permanence and gravity
and later in life you you even act in
the world now they're not going into
this
acting in the world but their point is
that
throughout your life you just observe
the world and you build these predictive
models and that's how you learn about
how the world works
i'm not entirely sure that things like
gravity are learned in this way i think
there's some evidence
that at least part of it is biological
or at least you're
extremely biologically predetermined to
learn
about things like object permanence and
gravity but the point is taken that
there is something built into you either
from experience or from biology
that allows you that is kind of this
common sense and that
allows you to acquire new tasks with
extremely
few additional samples because you bring
in this knowledge
uh about the world so their core
claim here is that we believe that
self-supervised
learning is one of the most promising
ways to build
such background knowledge and
approximate
a form of common sense in ai systems
they say the way we're going to get ai
systems to also have this common sense
knowledge
is by doing self-supervised learning
right so they give some examples of
self-supervised learning they also
contrast it with unsupervised learning
where the difference so they say
unsupervised learning is a bit of a
misnomer
learning is never really unsupervised
self-supervised learning specifically
means that you generate the label out of
the data
itself so what could that be
you know for example in invert the
language model
you might have a sentence like this
is a cat and
this is a sentence from the data set now
in self-supervised learning
you would somehow need to come up with
an input sample and a label for that
input sample
just by just using this text right in a
supervised
um in a supervised data set you would
have
some label associated with this and this
could be
anything depending on what the task is
like this
could be labels could be annotations for
what kind of words these words are
label could be whether or not the
sentence is a
positive or negative sentence but in
self-supervised learning
you can do something like this and
here's what bert does
they cross out uh a word
like this a so this now becomes the
input sample
x and the label is going to be
whatever was missing here so the label
will be
the word a now the task of the machine
learning system is
given x figure out what is y
okay so figure out that at this
particular place
in the sentence there should be the uh
word
a now bird does a bit more sophisticated
things like it also replaces tokens and
so on but ultimately
what you want is for any for
any corrupted input to for the system to
output the
uncorrupted output and
thereby the system will learn about the
world
it will maybe not about the world but it
will learn about language
if it wants to do this task correctly it
needs to learn
that if you have a this is
construction there should probably be
some kind of specifier for
what comes next right here and then cat
is some sort of an object or animal
so given all of this evidence you
only have very few possibilities like a
or
my or this is
a one this is two cat no this is your
cat
something like this but all the other
words in the language cannot
be so they formulate self-supervised
learning
as obtaining supervisory signals from
the data itself that's why it's not
unsupervised it is self-supervised
because you create
the label from the data and the
important part here
is and i think that's often neglected in
these self-supervised things
is that the way you create the label
from the data that is human specified
right
this this step right here that needs
can i draw a light bulb
that needs a human idea
like how could we create a label
and an input data point given a data
point
so we shift the burden of the human
from labeling the data explicitly to
simply
saying to simply constructing the method
of how to obtain
labels from data this is still building
in
substantial human bias but it is much
more scalable if i have one method to
create labels
i can apply it to an entire data set
whereas if i
create labels myself i have to go
through
every single data point right but it's
not unsupervised because the supervision
is in the process that creates the label
so they say leverage the underlying
structure of the data the general
technique
of self-supervised learning is to
predict any unobserved or hidden part or
property
of the input from any observed or
unhidden part of the input
so the general recipe or one i would say
one general recipe because it's not
the general recipe even though they
claim it here
i would say one general recipe is that
if you have an input
you just hide part of it and then you
have the model predict
that hidden part they give a bunch of
examples here this is
quite a cryptic drawing i think so these
are three examples
of what you could do if you have
data and this yeah time or space i would
claim it's easiest if you think of this
as a video
sequence so this is a video sequence and
the frames are all they're stacked
like this frame frame
frame okay and
it goes up until here so what you're
going to do
what you can do option one is
you simply take the past you define a
time point t
right here and you take the past and
that's the observed part
and you take the future which you have
in your data set
but you don't show it to the model so
the model is supposed to predict
the future from the past this
in video you can understand it this is
also what for example
gp the gpt models do like gpt3
does exactly this it takes in a
the past words so far and it predicts
the next word or the next
few words the second part is
you don't have to necessarily predict
the future
you can also just leave away a bunch of
frames in the middle
somewhere at different parts now what
the model has to do is has to reason
about a part let's say this part right
here it has to reason
given the surrounding evidence so it
takes all the evidence into account
and it reasons what kind of frames could
have been left out there
in again in video in nlp land this would
be
something like bert so bert is trained
in this
objective uh as a as a masked language
model
and then the last one is really quite
specific
i think to something like video
maybe also different modalities but
doesn't apply super well to
nlp maybe you could though but
this is where if you imagine this being
your frames
you not only do you leave away
these frames right here but you also
would leave away
part of the frames that you observe so
in these frames
you would simply only observe the
bottom right thing right here and you
would not
observe everything else so not only do
you have to reason about
what goes into the missing slot but you
also have to reason about
what goes into the parts of the frames
you don't observe
and as you can see here these can be
different parts
uh throughout the video so i think it's
just
it just makes a a point that this can be
quite
general so in general you just hide
parts of your input
and you re-predict them from a model
and that means the model you know if it
can for example if it can predict
the future of a video from the past
given
you know certain input it will
necessarily
have to learn something about how the
world works or at least
about how the world looks through a
video lens
right if it does this task well it
has a lot of prop captured a lot of
properties of how the world looks in
in video and that is much more rich
information than simply giving a label
to train on
and the hope is that by learning all of
these different things
that are necessary to predict the future
well from the past
the model will learn such a useful
representation
that adapting this model to solve any
labeled
supervised task is going to be really
quick because it also it
already has very very good
representation of the data
and the common thing here is that
okay in order to predict the in order
from the past to the future
there can be there can be numerous
features that are
helpful right there are all of these
features that are very helpful
uh to predict the future from the past
now
if i have any supervised task right i
have for example the past
and then i want to determine if
i don't know um what can we determine
from a video
if if this is a happy video right is
this a happy video
or not the uh the core assumption here
is that
since you know predicting the future
from the past has sort of the structure
of the world built in and since our
supervised
task is probably a function of a subset
of that structure like whether or not
it's a happy video
probably depends on whether or not in
the future someone will fall off a cliff
or not right so sub a subset
of these things in combination are going
to be
relevant for that task so they can be
adapted
since the representation is already
there they can be adapted pretty rapidly
while the ones that are not important
can maybe be overwritten
and relearned to get some additional
signal from the from the input that was
not learned
in the in the self-supervised training
so
the goal is again by learning to predict
the hidden inputs
from the non-hidden inputs you learn
about the structure of the data
by learning about the structure of the
data you get useful representations
and by having useful representations you
can adapt
very quickly to new tasks that's the
that's the sort of argument here
so why don't we do this all the time
every time everywhere
they go into self-supervised learning
for language
versus vision so in language this is
uber duper successful while in vision i
think in vision it's
fairly successful too but there is a
challenge when you think about
language versus vision specifically in
terms of
this hiding hiding parts of the inputs
and then reconstructing them so
there are two there are two different
things that we need to consider here
the first thing the first problem is
dimensionality
and the second thing we need to consider
is uncertainty
okay so dimensionality
in nlp is
what's our dimensionality if you think
of this problem again
this is a cap this thing right here
how do we do it in bert like we mask out
the word
and then we feed this sentence we feed
it through a big neural network
that is bert
and then at the end at this position we
attach a classification head so this is
a classifier
that classifies into the whole
vocabulary
so what we end up with is we have our
whole vocabulary so there is the word a
there is the word is there is the word
cat
there is the word dog there is the word
mom
there are all these words right we can
actually enumerate
all of these words and because we can
enumerate them
we can let the model output a
distribution
so maybe it says well the word a is you
know
super likely the word is not so likely
the word cat
it appears in the sentence you know the
observed sentence so it might be a bit
like the word dog
the word mom not really and so on so
what we get is a discrete
probability distribution note that
the dimensionality even though it's
sometimes large so this
it can be something like 30k it's still
countable we can still do a
classification into
30 000 different classes especially if
we use wordpieces we don't have out of
vocabulary
we can actually choose our vocabulary
size second of all
we can actually represent our
uncertainty notice that not all the
weight here is on the word a
especially if there is also like your
which is also
possible but in this case not correct
the model can express the fact
that it thinks that both words could fit
into this
thing so if there is this is zero this
is
one over here that probably adds up to
more than one
in any case you can see that
the top prediction here is only maybe
0.4
in probability so the model can
represent uncertainty by simply not
allocating all of the classification
mask
to a single thing
so these two things are solved pretty
well dimensionality
is you know high but not too high
and uncertainty can be represented now
what about computer vision
and that's where they they have this
diagram right here
that sort of is supposed to sort of
detail
what i just said in that nlp tasks
these masked prediction tasks they have
they're rather discreet okay
they have relatively less
well they're relatively low dimensional
and have less uncertainty
i'm not really sure if the less
uncertainty
and they have a better i would say they
have a better way of representing
uncertainty and then the fact that they
have less uncertainty simply comes from
the fact that they are more
discrete and low dimensional than other
problems
so what do i mean by more discrete
lower dimensional and so on if you look
at vision problems
if you think what do i need to do to
predict
a video right and let's let's even go
let's even go simpler than that let's
take
a common task in self-supervised
learning
so i have an image
the images of a cat let's say like i
know
you're surprised ears eyes
let's that is a cruel cat
okay so
that is one cat okay
and i mask away part of an image so i
simply cut out this part here
and my model is supposed to reconstruct
the part
from the known parts that is a
self-supervised
task is exactly in the category of what
they suggest
here now can we do the same thing
as we do in the nlp thing
remember in the nlp thing we made a
model
that output a classifier
over all the possible things that could
go in there
like no we cannot well first of all
how many things are there that can go
there
um well infinity because
this is a continuous problem right so if
i give you
a patch and you know here is a part of
the head this and maybe the whiskers you
can see
this it could technically be right
but it could also be that
the cat here because we don't know right
an equally
likely continuation is that the cat is
like holding
a wine glass right here that is filled
with
wine we don't we don't know right
uh an equally likely continuation like
there are
infinitely many likely continuations
for this for filling in and that's a bit
the same
as in the nlp task because there are
multiple words that could fill that slot
but way less plus we
can we will never be able to enumerate
all of the different patches that could
and could not go in there right
we could we can't even enumerate all the
ones that could go in there
and it's completely impossible to list
all the ones that are
both possible and non-possible so we
could build a classifier on top of it so
we simply cannot
like this this we cannot build a
classifier this is not
possible in the vision case so it is too
high dimensional
and also there is no good way of
representing
uncertainty there is much more and i get
it
well i think the dimensionality has a
direct effect on the uncertainty
so what people do or what people can do
is they
they say let's not build a classifier
let's actually
just predict what is there right because
i can do a neural network like a cnn
something like this layer layer layer
layer layer layer like a unit
with some skip connections right here
right and i can actually
try to train my model to just
reconstruct that part
right like how how hard is this like we
said at the beginning instead of
this is a this is a very terrible cut
but you know the model is not trained
super well so it only has one eye
um the model doesn't help me
the model isn't trained super well so i
can just
program or i can train my model to
reconstruct but now
all my model can do is it can output one
thing it can only output one completion
if i don't have a classifier
where i can represent my probability
distribution i can only output
a thing and since there are many i have
no way of representing many
and i can't really output the mean of
them because the mean of these two
pictures is going to be not a real
picture because it's like a half
transparent wine glass
right so that's certainly invalid so
you can as you can see the fact that we
can't build
an explicit classifier means we have to
predict directly but then since we can't
predict directly we have no
way of representing uncertainty
so i wouldn't call this more uncertainty
i would call it
that computer vision has less of a
possibility to represent
uncertainty directly i think that's
something they say in the text
actually um so that is the problem
with computer vision now what do people
do
to tackle this and the answer is going
to be contrastive
learning but they go there
in a bit first they make an excursion to
energy-based
models so here they say a unified view
of
self-supervised methods even though i
thought
this hiding part of the input was
already the unified view but
in any case they say there is a way to
think about self-supervised
learning within the unified framework of
an energy-based
model now a short pre thing here
from me i you know this energy-based
model and you'll see what it is
in a second i think
that is just kind of a it doesn't tell
me anything like the term
energy based model it can just be
applied to
anything like any problem like energy
based
model simply means loss function
right but yeah let's so an energy based
model is a trainable system that given
two inputs x and y
tells us how incompatible they are with
each other for example
x could be a short video clip and why
another proposed video
clip the machine would tell us to what
extent
y is a good continuation for x to
indicate the incompatibility between x
and y
the machine produces a single number
called an energy if the energy is low x
and y are deemed compatible
if it is high they are deemed
incompatible so this is kind of a
physics
approach to the thing so if you again
think of this as your video
and you want to predict the future from
the past
what an energy-based model would do
is it would um it had two components
so the main component would be this
energy function right here and the
energy function would tell you
how well x and y fit together
so now it's you can actually put both
frameworks
in this so if you predict why
right if you if your model actually
predicts
the continuation then your energy
function could
simply be something like the l2 loss
between the actual
true um between the true
continuation in your data and the one
you predicted
however if you do if you could if you
could do the classifier
approach and you could actually list all
the video sequences that are possible
then your energy function could be
something like
um could be the classifier loss
but you know again so if you
think about this then anything is an
energy-based model
right a classification problem is an
because if i have an image here of my
trusty cat
and i have the label cat right my f
of x and y is simply
if i define my energy function as
my cross entropy between um
you know as my classification cross
entropy of cat
given all the other labels that is an
energy based model
right it's so i don't see why
we need to frame this as energy based
model if we can simply say
loss function like beats me
but in any case um i guess the sort of
physics approach here is just another
way of thinking about it
but i dare anyone to bring me a
thing that is
not an energy-based model in machine
learning
i might have just uh summoned some
demons here okay
so they go back and say well look the
the an early example of this are these
siamese networks that have recently
become fashionable again
and that is where you do the following
so now we switch away from predicting
this hidden
part from the unhidden part and we go
more into the predicting
a hidden property part so here you can
see you have
two different crops of an image and this
is the most
popular self-supervised task for
computer vision
you have an image of something like the
sun
and you crop it twice in different
locations so you crop it here
you crop it here and what your
what your model needs to do is it needs
to figure out that these two patches
come from the same image if it can do
that
then it will have learned some good
representation
and if you regularize correctly then it
learns an even better representation
so here it needs to figure out that
these two chess
uh looking things actually come from
a similar picture and the hope is so
okay what do they do they feed each of
the ones through the same encoder
right and the w in the middle means that
the weights of the encoder are shared
so you obtain two hidden representation
and then this here
this could simply be you know like the
inner product between
h and h prime or like
the negative inner product if you want
to actually make it as an energy
so or maybe one over the inner product
however
you formulate it but what this will do
is it will tell the model if two things
come from the same um image you better
have representations for them these h
that agree with each other which means
that they are close in the inner product
space they have a high inner product
if this is the case right then it means
that you have learned something useful
about the world
because you can tell me when two crops
are from the same image and the hope is
that the model will learn that oh wait
if you know if the model wants to do
this well it needs to learn
aha there are chess pieces in here it
can't simply
compare maybe you can compare these
pixels okay that will work
but if you compare this pixel and this
pixel that won't work
so it needs to learn something more
sophisticated actually needs to learn
there are chess pieces in here if it
wants to do a good job and differentiate
representations from those with crops
from different images like if we have a
crop from the sun
right here what we want is that the
inner product between these two
is high but the inner product between
any with
anyone with a part of the sun picture is
low okay so we train it like this and
this is exactly where the contrastive
learning
goes so these siamese networks they look
fun
but without the part i just outlined
without the contrastive part
they fall into danger of collapse so if
i only
ever input two crops from the same image
and say
please make the hidden representation
such that the inner product is high
um what i what i will
end up with is a model that simply
collapses and always gives me the same
hidden representation for every single
image because that satisfies the
constraint
right and that's what they point out
here
this phenomenon is like the network
could happily ignore their inputs and
always produce identical output
embeddings
this phenomenon is called a collapse
when a collapse occurs
the energy is not higher for
non-matching x and y
than it is for matching x and y so they
say the uh
the easy part is the easy part
is that when vectors
when x and y are slightly different
versions of the same image the system is
trained to produce a low energy
okay so now that's easy the difficult
part is to train the model so that it
produces a
high energy for images that are
different
now what counts as different and
non-different here again is
much of human supervision so this task
of cropping
that has fundamental assumptions that
you know for example in one
image there is largely one object or one
topic that we're interested in
right if this is a map and we actually
want to differentiate the places it's a
pretty bad task to do this cropping
also what people do a lot is color
jittering color
inversions brightness modifications all
of these
is human intuition human supervision
that
the color shouldn't matter the
brightness shouldn't matter and so on
and the more things you give to the
model like this
the more you bake in your assumptions
so again we we move from supervised
learning
where we tell the model here's the
correct label here's the correct label
to self-supervised learning where we
tell the model
sort of we tell the model what what kind
of transformations
should and shouldn't matter and the
model has to figure out
itself how to create the representation
such that these constraints hold
so now they go into the solutions for
collapse they say they're avoid
there are two techniques to avoid
collapse one is contrastive methods
and the other one is regularization
methods
so contrastive methods they actually
have this graphic
right here as you can see
so their point is that
if we talk about energy based models we
want energy to be low
on x y pairs that we as humans
define match so this could be because we
crop them
from the same image or we actually it is
the same image but slightly distorted
in different ways so we as humans we
simply determine
these two things match or it is the
uncorrupted and the corrupted version of
the same sentence in birds training
and these here are represented by the
blue points so we want the energy to go
down on the blue points but we want the
energy to go
up everywhere else right everywhere
where it doesn't match
we want the energy to be high now
what could we do we could simply
you know push down here because we can
create lots of examples
right we can create lots of samples
where x and y match because we don't
need labels anymore we can create the
labels ourselves so we can create lots
and lots and lots and lots of
of image crop pairs that match right
so the pushing down isn't the problem
the pushing up is the
problem now if you see this graphic you
might say why don't i just
you know enumerate or kind of go through
here and i push
up on all the green places right i push
just
up and up here and up here up here the
problem
with that is that the higher the
dimensionality
the less possible that is and here is
where the graphic tricks you
into thinking that it's a good idea when
it's actually not
like you will not be able to enumerate
all the green dots even around the blue
dots like it's just not possible because
the dimensionality is
so high if you have a dot
in 512 dimensions that is a vector
with 512 entries right 512
entries now you would need to
let's say if you were just to look
around
a data point you would need to jiggle
the first dimension maybe to the left
and to the right
and the second dimension and the third
dimension and you need to do this all
combinatorically so you would need to do
this one to the right this one to the
left this one to the left
and then this one to the right this one
to the right
this one to the left and so on you need
to do it in different
magnitudes here sometimes you need to
keep them constant
it's just not possible so what do people
do
in these contrastive methods they say
well we can't push up on all the points
but what we can do is we can sample and
that's why you see the green things
epileptically jumping around in that
we can sample the green points instead
of enumerating them
we simply sample them and that's where
we push up
and that is a difficult task to do
so it is difficult to come up with
examples
with sense with meaningful
negative examples because
so what people do
in this task right here is what i just
said
well here are two images that fit right
this is a blue point
and here are two images that don't fit
so this is a green point
however as you we already saw there are
many many more green points than blue
points and most
green points are really far apart from
the blue points
if i just take any image right here
it might be way too easy for the model
so the best thing would be
to give the model sort of a curriculum
or at least what we call
hard negatives but that is
computationally very expensive because
we have to go
search for heart negatives like images
that are
close but not but still different
uh would be best for the model but we
don't have that
all we can do is sort of randomly sample
crops from other images because
we don't have labels we have no clue if
you know two images are the same or not
we just scraped them from instagram come
on
um all looks all the same to me
so the problem here is that if we just
do it randomly
then most of the green points will
actually be pretty far apart
and that means we just have to train for
a long long time so contrastive methods
they work in computer vision
right now however
coming up with incompatible pairs that
will shape the energy in a suitable way
is challenging and expensive
computationally
at least in vision systems right um
the method used to train nlp systems by
maxing or substituting some input words
belongs to the category of contrastive
methods but they don't use
joint embedding architecture instead
they use a predictive architecture
okay so that's saying that them if
you look at what you know bert does with
this
it this this
masking one thing out and then classify
directly that is technically contrastive
because what you do
in a classification model is
you push up like these are all the
possibilities
and what you do during training is you
push up on the class that is correct
and you push down on the classes that
are not correct that's what the
cross-entropy loss does
so technically it is a contrastive
method however
you do this in this sort of predictive
framework you don't do it
via this method of having shared
embeddings
and that's because you can actually
enumerate all the things
that you could do right so
with the contrastive methods for vision
we can do
the same thing now what we can do
here if you think about this problem
again of
we cannot possibly enumerate all
possible pictures that go here
but what we can do is we can enumerate
a couple and then simply classify which
ones are
are good and which ones aren't and
that's exactly what these contrastive
methods do
that we just looked at right so we
sample
the green points we sample also the blue
points and then we simply
either classify between the green and
the blue points or
you know we make their inner product go
high at the end
these are not so much different
objectives
whether or not it's really a
classification loss or not the point
here is that
first they obtain shared embeddings they
obtain some sort of embedding
right here and then they make the
embedding agree or not agree
so they quickly go into what bert is
birdies is uh
usually called a denoising auto encoder
so what you have is you start off with a
data point with the uncorrupted version
you corrupt it
and that's the part where you mask out
some parts you can see this right here
you mask them out
and then you have a
prediction for what should go in the
blanks and the
loss here is simply the classification
loss this is just your cross
entropy loss that goes here
a vast language model which is an
instance of a denoising autoencoder
itself an instance of a contrastive
self-supervised learning
however there is another way there is
another
so here they talked about there are two
ways where we
in which we can combat this right there
are two categories oh
sorry about that there are two
categories so this is category one
is contrastive methods uh where we
classify
some against others either all of them
or a sample of them
however the other one is what they call
this this predictive
architecture oh sorry
no a predictive architecture of this
type can produce only a single
prediction for a given output
since the model must be able to predict
multiple possible outcomes
the prediction is not a single set of
words but a series of scores for every
word in the vocabulary for each missing
word location so that's still burped
uh bert which can give you
uncertainty by simply telling how likely
each word is
and here they say we cannot use this
trick for images because we cannot
enumerate
all possible images is there a solution
for this problem the short answer is
no there are interesting ideas in this
direction
but have not yet led to results that are
as good as joint embedding
architectures one interesting avenue is
latent variable predictive architectures
so that what you see down here this is a
so it goes down this is the description
that goes down here
latent variable predictive models
contain an extra input variable
z it is called latent because its value
is never observed
with a properly trained model as the
latent variable varies over a given set
the output prediction varies over the
set of plausible predictions compatible
with the
input x and the name
generative adversarial models here so
this is a bit a bit confusing but so
up here is the loss this is a loss and
um here you have this new variable z
and this z comes from a domain
right here where it can move around and
by by moving around z you actually move
around
the output y right here so they
represent this as this this curvy
curvy boy here um so as
so maybe z is here and that represents a
point here on the manifold but as you
move
z like to the right then you move along
this manifold
right here so this is a way in which a
model
can for a given x you can see here x is
mixed with z x is first you obtain a
representation for x then it's mixed
with
z for a given x you can produce many
different outputs by simply varying
z and if you sample
a bunch of these z and then calculate
sort of an average loss over them maybe
or just a loss per sample then
eventually you'll train your model to
not only
you know handle this one prediction but
handle many different
predictions now you might know gans so
gans are simply when you
do not have so when you so again
simply cuts off this here so gans only
have the z variable
and then they produce this set of
outputs and the this is the
discriminator right here
that decides between the real image and
the produced image
of course
the last thing here is that this r is
the regularization on
z i believe they never i don't think
they ever pointed out
what the r is but they also don't think
they ever point out what this
regularization is they talk up here
about
so i'm going to assume that refers to
the
r right here and now it gets a little
bit
it gets a little bit confusing so
they say um
down here
they say first of all they say
non-contrastive methods applied to joint
embedding architectures is possibly the
hottest topic in self-supervised
learning for vision at the moment domain
is still largely unexplored but it seems
very promising
so non-contrastive methods which means
they don't
need negative samples but they still do
joint embedding so they take two
different things
that come like from the same image they
jointly embed them but they don't have
negative samples like the original
siamese networks but you need to avoid
collapse and these
models right here for example there's
bjol which i have made a video about you
can check that out
i think they argue that batch norm for
some reason avoids this collapse if they
build in batch norm but also
there are other architectures right but
they all
um they they are in the beginning
and so they say rather than doing
non-contrastive joint embedding maybe
we should do essentially what bert is
doing
but for vision so perhaps a better
alternative in the long run will be to
devise
non-contrastive methods with latent
variable predictive models
so predictive is you know we predict the
output directly
like burt does but we can't envision
because we can't enumerate all the
possibilities so we can't represent
uncertainty
so what we should do is we should do
this latent variable thing
where we deterministically predict
right this is deterministic we
deterministically predict the embedding
and then from the embedding we construct
fuzzily
like with the by sampling z like we
sample z
from this ground distribution we
construct this entire set
of outputs and that will represent our
possibilities like our uncertainty that
will represent
all the things that could fill the gap
that we're trying to predict
so they say that may be the way forward
and then they say something confusing
the main obstacle is that they require a
way to minimize the capacity of the
latent
variable the volume of the set over
which the latent variable can vary
limits the volume of the outputs that
take a low energy by minimizing this
volume one
automatically shapes the energy in the
right way which sort of means that
yes if i have to limit this capacity of
this latent variable
right because otherwise the latent
variable could contain all the
information like in again
the latent variable contains all the
information and uh it's only actually
limited by the
by the generator right by what the
generator's weights are
so the latent variable contains
all of the information so technically
again something like a style gun could
happily ignore
the input right here and it could still
produce pretty good images
and you have to do tricks in order to
make the model actually pay attention
to the input and not only pay attention
to
the latent variable so you can
regularize you can constrain this latent
variable
such that the model pays attention to
the input and why do we want the model
to pay attention to the input
because the entire reason is that we
want to use this
embedding right here then for future
supervised learning like this embedding
that's actually the goal of
self-supervised learning
um there you see why gans probably
cannot give us
super good um embeddings because gans
just
have the part on the right okay
but something like an infogan or like as
we said like a style gan that takes an
input
could technically already give us is
technically a model
uh about something like this
though here they say
um so so that's you know you limit the
we
keep the you limit
the capacity of the latent variable
but then they go on and say a successful
example of such a method
is the variational auto encoder the vae
in which the latent variable is made
fuzzy which
limits its capacity okay and here is
where i
uh i i was i was confused but the vae
have not yet been shown to produce
good representations for downstream
visual tasks okay
another successful example is sparse
modeling but its use has been limited to
simple architectures
no perfect recipe seems to exist to
limit the capacity of the latent
variables
now i get that limiting capacity however
in a variational encoder it is not
exactly the latent variable that is made
fuzzy
it is actually the embedding right if
you think here
in a in a variational autoencoder what
you do is you have whatever your image
and then you have your encoder and then
you predict in the latent space you
predict gaussian distributions like you
predict the mean and you predict the
standard deviation
of a gaussian distribution and then you
sample from that gaussian
that is a horrible gaussian you sample
from that gaussian distribution
and due to the reparameterization trick
you can actually simply
sample from a standard gaussian down
here
like that is at zero and has standard
deviation one and that will be your
z variable and then you can simply do z
times
uh sorry z times sigma plus mu
and that will be sampling essentially
from
the um that will be sampling from that
respective gaussian so in this way
the variable z is not made fuzzy what is
actually made fuzzy
is this here and this here comes from
h right this is h this is the embedding
gives rise to these
mu and sigma and these are made fuzzy
because they're multiplied by a
stochastic
variable so i'm a little bit confused
about this paragraph right here because
a vae i don't think that it limits the
capacity
of the latent variable and fuzz is the
latent variable
but i might be wrong or they actually
mean something else by latent variable
they actually mean the
embedding here in that case it might
make sense again
however then it doesn't make super much
sense to limit its capacity
and i've also looked at this sporus
modeling which simply seems to be
kind of sparse encoding of of images
it's a really old paper from uh
69 but sorry
96 96 uh not that old
yeah but okay i'm simply going to
interpret this as
in order to obtain a meaningful
representation h
down here we need to limit the capacity
of the latent variable right here
because otherwise
the model will simply ignore the input
and
not build a good representation for it
so they argue
that an architecture like this an
architecture like a vae
like an infogan or something like this
could potentially be the next
step if we can make it work
the challenge in the next few of the
next few years may be to devise
non-contrastive methods for latent
variable energy-based model
that successfully produce good
representation of image video speech and
other signals and yield top performance
in downstream supervised tasks without
requiring large amounts of
labeled data so in german we have a
saying
uh that what they want is the uh ayaling
the volume
which means the egg laying wool
milk pig so it can do
anything and everything and it costs
nothing
um so that's what they mean again
some of these things like energy based
model like anything is an
energy based model i just i just don't
find this to be super
uh discriminating in its in its meaning
of what that of what that is lastly they
talk a bit about their new
model called uh seer which you know is a
self-supervised
model but it's just like a giant convent
trained on a billion images like
oh but you know they open sourced it
thank you you open source the code
uh so i can totally train my own
billion parameter on a
uh on a billion random
public instagram images because you know
my raspberry pi just
technically has that capacity so thanks
uh but you know
no but i'm i'm joking a little bit at
least
better than open ai
and at the end they go into how they use
other ways of self-supervised learning
at facebook
all right that was my overview over this
article i hope you got at least
something from it as a high-level
overview they first
say self-supervised learning is maybe
the way to get this common sense
into ai systems um
then they go into what is
self-supervised learning they define it
first as predicting
hidden parts from unhidden parts and
later they say it can be viewed as an
energy-based model that they
point out that there's a crucial
distinction between
tasks like language and vision because
vision is much more high dimensional
gives you much less of a way to
represent uncertainty
then they go on and say well
the contrastive methods handle part of
that
they handle this not uh they handle this
part of the dimensionality that you can
enumerate all the possible things
however they are prone to collapse sorry
you know the the siamese networks are
prone to collapse the contrastive
methods fix that however because you
have to sample
from such a i dimensional space and that
is really hard
it takes a lot of data and
what we could do is we could do these
predictive models that directly classify
the output
or directly predict the output right you
predict the missing frame you predict
the missing word
but we do it in this way where you not
only do you predict a single thing but
you predict an entire set by means
of these latent variable predictive
models and that
they say is maybe the way forward even
though it doesn't work too well
yet like via e's work but the problem is
they don't have this ability to generate
good representations for supervised
learning that just doesn't work
too well yet all right that was it
if you liked it leave a like subscribe
share doubt
tell me what you think in the comments
and bye bye